how much larger is our universe or is it
just a really weird shape the universe
is large and very uniform we can have
tried to measure the size of the
universe so it's at least 26 billion
light years across so we don't know
whether the universe is infinite or
finite but if it's finite it is really
big so we live in a big universe and we
see the same pattern of fluctuations
roughly in the different directions and
the fluctuations don't seem to have
anomalies they seem to be drawn from the
bell curve distribution that we call a
gaussian and the statistical properties
of the fluctuations are incredibly
simple the universe turns out to be so
simple that they can describe the
properties of those fluctuations by two
numbers the amplitudes or fluctuations
and how they vary with scale and that
completely characterizes it
foreign
[Music]